Speaker 1: when we talk about 2022. And I do
believe we are now officially in the mid-term
period. You know, we've been talking before about
usually the midterms really heat up in June or
July. And this time around, it might be May. It
might even be late April. I believe that with the
start of Trump's 2022 rallies over the weekend and
just with the amount of interest and discussion
that's already taking place about specific 2022
races, including Dr. Oz, I'm sorry. Mehmet Oz,
I'm doing it too. We need Mehmet Oz running
in Pennsylvania with the discussions about
what appear to be Eshoo and Trumpists that
will easily sail to reelection. You know,
many of their names, I won't repeat them. It seems
pretty clear that the 2022 midterms have begun.
And one of the reasons that the 2022 midterms are
important are that if Republicans take the House
in 2022, the investigation into the Trump riots
is over. So there's urgency for it to be completed
before the November elections. That's number one.
Number two, the success of Trump and Dorsey's in
2022 may well be a signal about 2024 in terms of
Trump's interest in running. Trump's likelihood in
running? OK, that's another reason. But there is
a third really important category as to why 2022
matters, which is depending on what happens in
2022, not only in the House and Senate, but very
importantly in races within states, governors,
secretaries of state. And here we go now.
Elections supervisors The Republican
Party may be in a better position in 2024
to successfully steal an election. They
unsuccessfully tried to steal an election in 2020,
depending on what happens in 2022. They may
be in a real position to actually succeed
at stealing an election in 2024. And we have
video here of Donald Trump just admitting it.
This is video and remember, they tried with
Raffensperger in Georgia and it didn't work,
but had different people been there. In
Georgia, it might actually have worked.
So here. Donald Trump in a video message to the
Pennsylvania Republican Party, he explains why
he is focusing on supervisor of elections
races in 2022. He's admitting the strategy
out loud. My friends, take a look at this.
Speaker 2: Would be a lot sharper the next
time when it comes to counting the vote. There's
a famous statement. Sometimes the vote counter
is more important than the candidate, and we
can't let that ever, ever happen again. They
have to get tougher and smarter.
Speaker 1: So when Trump says
we need tougher and smarter people counting
the ballots running elections, what he's saying
is we need to more effectively put our people
in control of elections so that when I lose,
I can just have someone figure out a way to make
me win. Remember him demanding the 11000 votes?
Speaker 3: I need 11000
votes. Give me a break, right?
Speaker 1: That was with Georgia. So
we've known that this is the strategy.
And Donald Trump is admitting that this is the
strategy. And this is one of the major reasons
why Donald Trump is going to be so involved in
the 2022 races. They are going to try again. And
remember, we've we've gone through these different
scenarios. If Trump had had some friendlier people
in three or four states, it's not a guarantee.
That it would have gone a different way,
but it would have significantly upped
the odds that even though Trump lost,
he might have been able to stay in power it up the
odds. I'm not saying it made it likely, but it up.
The odds, if Raffensperger had been willing, could
have flipped Georgia, right? I mean, at the end of
the day, 11000 votes, as Donald Trump said, we've
now heard from retired generals from the military
who have warned and said if the military brass
had been willing and interested in helping,
you could have had the assistance of the military
in carrying out the coup. Trump didn't have it in
2020. What if that changed? And there is no doubt
whatsoever where this is heading? Joseph Stalin
said in 1923 quote, I consider it completely
unimportant. Who in the party will vote or
how? But what is extraordinarily important is this
who will count the votes and how? And he is saying
that he wants them to be better at stealing
elections period. And so how do we? I've talked
before about the difficulty of playing defense
against this. They might have 12 strategies and we
need to know all 12 and know how to defend against
them. We might only know how to defend against 11.
And that 12th strategy is what could be the
difference maker. So they're doing gerrymandering,
of course, for help at the state level. They
are working on voter suppression, closing
polling places, restricting early voting hours.
Strategically, all of these different things voter
roll purges on the full list and now openly saying
We need our supervisors of elections in place
in order to make this more plausible that we would
succeed next time. And this is part of why 2022 is
so important. I hope that the Left understands the
importance of 2022 midterms that always, you know,
compared to two general elections, midterms have
lower turnout and it's so kind of cliche and
I don't know what other word to apply to it to say
these are very important midterms, particularly
important midterms. And there's always some
reason why someone will say this is the most
important election in a very specific sense, which
is when it comes to trying to steal the elections
when they don't win. Twenty twenty two could be
the Rubicon, where once it is crossed, it will
be very, very difficult to go back. And so we are
going to be getting back into, you've got to vote,
you've got to vote. And I know it became a broken
record leading up to the 2020 election. But
everyone must vote not just because if Republicans
take control of the House and Senate, it will be a
disaster for the United States, not just because
Trumpian candidates winning makes it more likely.
Trump runs in 2024. And quite frankly, I think
I think Trump in 24 beats Joe Biden or Kamala.
I've said that before some of you agree, some of
you disagree, but also because 2022 is going to be
part of the plan for better positioning themselves
to steal future elections, which would be an
absolute and total nightmare. We're going to take
a break and be back with some very interesting
news headlines. Your voicemail and so many other
things. Stay with us. We will be right back.